[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrados
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 en el que ya saben cada semana
analizamos un tema de actualidad con
nuestros corresponsales de la prensa
extranjera y analistas aquí desde
nuestros estudios en parís tras unas
semanas de descanso por el verano aquí
en europa hoy volvemos a este estudio
volvemos en primera plana y lo hacemos
para analizar el tema que canalizar la
rentrée aquí en francia con el miedo al
coronavirus la reentré escolar la
reentré también para los trabajadores y
también la reentré política mucho que
analizar y para ello contamos en ese
estudio con beatriz juez corresponsal
del diario el mundo bienvenida a beatriz
enric bonet corresponsal del público y
avant bienvenido buenos días y olivier
urrutia director del observatorio
europeo de think tanks bienvenido a
olivier por a buenos días la red entre
más atípica hoy aquí en primera plana
[Música]
no es una rentrée muy al uso todos con
mascarilla tanto en las escuelas como en
las empresas con miedo permanente a una
segunda ola de contagios por el
coronavirus seguimiento casi a diario de
cualquier noticia sobre una posible una
eventual vacuna y todo ello intentando
una recuperación económica de hecho esta
semana el gobierno francés ha presentado
su plan de relanzamiento todo ello
coincidiendo con el inicio de las clases
muchos interrogantes entre profesores
entre alumnos entre padres y todo ello
tras un verano en el que el gobierno
francés especialmente su primer ministro
ya en castres ha hecho multitud de
llamamientos para la precaución para la
responsabilidad ante el aumento de
contagios especialmente en algunas
ciudades como parís o marsella vamos a
ver como toda esta realidad la está
tratando la prensa francesa diario la
cual haciendo referencia a ese plan de
relanzamiento presentada esta semana por
el gobierno de jean caster 100.000
millones para borrar la crisis dice la
liberación ha llevado a su portada a los
múltiples retos que tiene el presidente
mccrone en esta rentrée
dice liberación confianza tengo un plan
le figaro escuela empresas una rentrée
con la dificultad de llevar mascarilla
en todos los contextos públicos bueno
les quiero preguntar por su percepción
para arrancar tras un verano con este
aumento de contagio especialmente entre
los más jóvenes y aumento de las medidas
como el uso de mascarilla la
generalización del uso de mascarilla de
forma obligatoria beatriz si comparamos
con antes de las vacaciones el
sentimiento que tenemos un poco hacia
primeras es de más tranquilidad o no yo
estoy más tranquila viendo a todos los
franceses con mascarilla porque antes de
las vacaciones la gente que lleva
mascarilla eran casi un raro aquí
en en parís era muy poca gente llegaba y
luego pues también es estoy más
tranquila para la parte porque
ahora estamos contando en los medios
están contando números de infectados y
no muertos que psicológicamente cambia
mucho y también nos estamos cada día más
cerca de la vacuna aunque a mejor tarde
o temprano temprano algunos nos
contagiamos es inevitable pero pero no
sé yo
prefiero verlo con esperanza de hecho la
medida estrella del verano ha sido la
mascarilla obligatoria enric y no ha
sido fácil porque al principio por
ejemplo ciudades como parís se había
establecido una cartografía de en
algunas calles y en algunas calles no
ahora de repente todas las calles porque
era un lío en los colegios que la va a
llevar y luego encontramos países como
españa que son muy restrictivos con el
tema de la mascarilla donde sin embargo
parece que esta segunda ola está siendo
muy fuerte es decir hay contradicciones
y encima de la mesa sí sin duda porque
la mascarilla es puede ser una medida
útil pero seguramente no es la nueva
solución a todos los problemas porque
mando hemos visto cómo va a solucionar
españa y quizás más vale semana más
tarde en francia que básicamente se
están adoptando medidas generales
toda la población sería obligatoria
desde hace unas dos semanas en parís en
las calles también esta semana
mascarilla obligatoria las oficinas pero
pienso también tendrá que llegar el
momento donde se focalicen que las
tendrán que ser medidas más quirúrgicas
en las poblaciones más débiles por
ejemplo vivimos en primavera no tanto en
francia como en españa donde donde hubo
unos niveles de mortalidad muy elevados
las residencias residencias de ancianos
la wta que se les era muy importante si
se adoptan las buenas medidas para
evitar nuevos contagios en estas zonas
también no poblaciones de riesgo por
ejemplo que en parís fue muy importante
los niveles de mortalidad en la valiente
que es donde ellos donde había muchas
personas que tenían problemas de para
aislarse dentro de sus propios
domicilios para hacer pequeños convenido
precarios no pues yo creo que ahora
probablemente uno de los desafíos del
gobierno a partir de ahora no será sólo
estas medidas generales sino que las
medidas más quirúrgicas para focalizarse
en distintos tipos de poblaciones de
riesgo a pesar del recrudecimiento de
casos durante este verano para el
gobierno francés el objetivo es hacer lo
que sea con fin de evitar un re
confinamiento generalizado un segundo
reconocimiento que sería brutal para la
economía ésta
hoy por hoy o libia está descartada es
algo que no está sobre la mesa no bueno
a ver yo no voy a hablar como experto de
link órgano virus hay que ser humilde
con algo que no conocemos bien yo voy a
hablar como ciudadanos y como todo el
mundo creo que de momento esa opción
está descartada por varios motivos uno
el aspecto económico obviamente que ha
causado estragos el primer confinamiento
y el segundo motivo es lo que acaban de
decir me mis compañeros es que de
momento hay más infectados pero no hay
más muertos y mientras el hospital los
servicios de emergencia no están
saturados exactamente yo creo que no va
a haber confinamiento porque no hay
motivo para ello y ahora se están
haciendo también muchos tests por
ejemplo estos masivos gratuitos aquí en
parís han empezado a hacer los de esta
semana entonces se hace también la s
a encontrar los casos antes lo que será
por lo que serán menos graves porque se
podrá tratar antes el caso dice el
gobierno que está realizando actualmente
830 mil test semanales con perspectivas
de llegar estas próximas semanas al
millón de tests semanales el otro gran
tema es la rentrée escolar que ha
generado polémica pero el gobierno se
basa en el argumento de que no se podía
retrasar desde el 1 de septiembre por
que retrasarlas supondría aumentar la
desigualdad comparten el argumento sí yo
creo que es una buena noticia de que los
niños hayan vuelto a la escuela de la
misma forma que en francia
empezaron a volver de más o menos
progresiva a partir de mayo de mayo pues
ahora que hay a la rentrée ha empezado
el 1 de septiembre es una buena noticia
luego es cierto yo creo que estar entre
escolar por todo respecto a la pandemia
muestra un poco el momento está un poco
parado ojalá que estamos en francia que
por un lado no un poco se fueron
adaptando un poco las medidas ya poco a
poco y de hecho y es una rentrée donde
básicamente la gran medida más
importante ha sido el uso de la
mascarilla para los alumnos de 11 años y
para todos los profesores que antes no
era el caso para los profesores de
primaria pero al mismo tiempo hemos
visto como algunos
resulta un poco menos restrictivas de
las que eran en mayo no porque ha dicho
una parte del dispositivo que el
protocolo que se ha utilizado era que en
julio cuando la enfermedad circulaba un
poco y que luego lo han ido adaptando no
pero que nos muestra un poco esa
situación un poco de incertidumbre donde
donde no se sabe muy bien si hay que
adoptar medidas más restrictivas para
evitar una circulación
de la epidemia más rápida o al mismo
tiempo poco a poco ir reduciendo esas
restricciones para intentar normalizar
la situación y conjugado con toda esta
situación la necesidad de relanzar la
economía esta semana el gobierno francés
presentó un plan de lanzamiento de un
monto realmente histórico 100 mil
millones de euros para que se hagan una
idea tras la crisis de la deuda
el plan que sacó francia para que
entonces el presidente sarkozy fue
cuatro veces inferior es decir es un
monto realmente importante se basa en
tres pilares en la creación de empleo la
sostenibilidad ecológica y la cohesión
territorial claro es muy complicado
enfrentarse una cifra si en frío pero es
lo suficientemente ambicioso dado las
circunstancias este plan
olivier como podríamos dar algún
elemento para calibrar
de una cifra así lo que tú has dicho es
histórico
eso sí suficiente no sabes no lo sabemos
aún habrá que ver y sobre todo yo
siempre desconfió un poco de esos
anuncios
que veo muy espectaculares pero lo más
interesante no es solo la cifra es que
se hace con ella en que se invierte
realmente cómo se usa cómo se distribuye
cómo se invierte de momento conocemos
los tres pilares pero yo también lo que
vi es que hasta ahora se ha ayudado
mucho a las grandes empresas que no eran
las que más necesitaban ayuda y se ha
dejado un poco más de lado a muchas
pequeñas empresas que sí necesitaban más
apoyo con lo cual yo
me quedo a la espera de ver cómo
exactamente se van a se va a usar se van
a usar esos millones por ejemplo como se
hizo en eeuu porque en eeuu lo que
hicieron fue mandar un cheque con una
firma de trump que le firmara ambigua y
una carta de whitehouse explicando por
qué por qué les mandaban el cheque para
que la gente gastará ahora
ayer dijo a los franceses hay que hay
que gastar no ahorrar para relanzar la
economía pero que los franceses esos 100
mil millones no los tienen en el
bolsillo si te dan 2.500 euros puestos
puedes gastar en lo que sea pero es como
un concepto diferente no un plan
encaminado a la inversión y al lo que
dice mi compañera beatriz ha de dar
confianza a la gente de cierta forma
para que la gente esos ahorros los ponga
en circulación e invierta y consuma lo
que pasa que no parece una tarea tan
fácil no si es nube para que como
comentando los compañeros ahora uno de
los aspectos de pensar a subrayar de
este plan y qué es lo que resulta un
poco más extraño de este plan es que
está muy basado en la competitividad de
las empresas en la oferta no que sea
política económica
la oferta que queráis de intentar
mejorar la competitividad de su empresa
para reactivar la economía pero ahora lo
que vemos con los grandes problemas que
tenemos ahora es un problema de demanda
que es un poco lo que intento hacer eeuu
en primavera el confinamiento que la
gente aunque quisiera gastar seguramente
no lo iban a hacer pero estamos en un
momento que seguramente para reactivar
la economía un gran desafío será eso si
los franceses van a empezar a gastar más
que por un lado tienen un colchón de que
hicieron no en durante estos meses de
confinamiento que la gente ahorra un
poco pues hay una capacidad de gastar
pero ese colchón estable que se termina
rápido con la crisis económica y es
verdad que las grandes dudas desde
planes del hecho desde mi punto de vista
si no es un poco esclavo de bombo de la
propia ideología del gobierno de creer
de que es siempre hay que focalizarse
más de la competividad de las empresas
bajar la fiscalidad de las empresas
porque son medidas que en francia se han
hecho se llevará a cabo desde 2014 y que
hasta ahora han dado unos resultados un
poco con muchos claroscuros
unos resultados que nos aclaró que hayan
sido exitosos
a lo que dicen que además estamos
enfrente a un tropismo francés que es
uno de los países que más ahora es decir
una costumbre hay aquí que la gente
ahorra bastante entonces obviamente en
un periodo además de crisis y de mucha
incertidumbre la gente tiene todavía más
miedo que en general y exigirle ahora
que se ponga a invertir cuando no lo ha
no lo hace en tiempos normales yo creo
que sí ya que hay una dificultad pero en
toral por hacer un poco de abogado del
por parte del gobierno es verdad
que a un gobierno o ya un presidente en
el que tantas veces el acusado de
liberal del neoliberalismo ahora de
repente pone los millones encima de la
mesa' intentando corregir los errores
que se cometieron después de la deuda de
2008 con una estrategia completamente
distinta quizá la crítica tenga que ir
en otro sentido
que se le puede hacer han protegido
bastante a las empresas también haciendo
con lo que en españa se llama arte y
aquí son más macs y el dando a los
trabajadores en vez de que la gente
fuese directamente se fuese a la calle
directamente porque cierran sus empresas
pues ha hecho un colchón en eso
y luego el govern argumenta que sé que
esta crisis puede acelerar una
transición ecológica no sé si ustedes
confían en ello si esto es evidente que
es otra parte muy importante el plan de
que hay unos 30 mil millones destinados
de transición ecológica que es algo que
en 2008 prácticamente no existió no
sabemos prácticamente un cambio de época
y que se van a hacer muchas inversiones
y que que muchas de ellas parecen
positivas en ese sentido sí que parece
que lo están es más avanzado en este
aspecto de verde quizás la única duda
sería de que es verdad que hay
muchísimas medidas hay 70 medidas de
nivel de ecología y muchos sectores que
quiera invertir en la duda de si el
hecho de invertir en tantos sectores sea
suficiente para que francia pueda ser
realmente un país puntero en estos
sectores que parecen los sectores del
futuro después de la pausa les quiero
preguntar por los otros temas claves de
esta rentrée entre otros el macrojuicio
que está abierto en parís por los
atentados de echarle abdo en 2015 será
la vuelta de la causa
ah
[Música]
en eeuu como en la mayoría de países del
mundo mucha gente se tuvo que quedar en
casa a raíz de la pandemia de el
coronavirus o por eso se registraron
grandes datos de audiencia por ejemplo
en la televisión convencional pero los
podcast fueron en parte también los
grandes beneficiados según apuntan
algunos estudios son muchísima gente se
habría suscrito a este tipo de servicios
durante la época de el coronavirus en el
país norteamericano aunque las
principales plataformas como spotify oa
por 'news de que no han dado la cifra
exacta de ese incremento si quien
reconocido que hubo un gran aumento de
suscriptores los estudios apuntan que el
grupo poblacional comprendido entre los
12 y los 34 años serían los que más
escuchan este tipo de contenidos hasta
10 podcast semanales lo que pondría de
manifiesto dicen los expertos a que es
una buena alternativa tanto para los
creadores de contenido como para el
público en general
[Música]
la pandemia del cob y se le otorgó
tiempo a los peruanos para acceder a
plataformas digitales que les permite
aprendizaje e información
entretenimiento ya conocer otras
disciplinas las estructuras tecnológicas
más empleadas son books
spotify google podcast y deezer las que
tienen gran demanda este punto
tecnológico ha motivado aún más a la
biblioteca nacional a lanzar su
plataforma digital para préstamo
gratuito de libros por beneplácito de
los amantes a la lectura el organismo
digital hizo más de 70 mil materiales
miles de usuarios pueden acceder a
diversos títulos los expertos señalan
que en el confinamiento han sido los
podcasts los que han permitido a muchos
viajar virtualmente escuchar grandes
relatos o ampliar los horizontes al
conocimiento ya no hundirse en el
aburrimiento esta coyuntura le ha valido
ha olido una plataforma inteligente
española ingresar a perú para ofrecer un
sistema educativo de aprendizaje algo
así como un streaming del conocimiento
en la que los usuarios pueden programar
los contenidos que más les interesa o
por inercia el sistema les va haciendo
recomendaciones personalizadas tal como
ocurre en netflix o spotify
[Música]
este año ha habido una explosión en la
popularidad de los podcasts aquí en el
reino unido con casi 7 millones de
personas que escuchan este formato
semanalmente de acuerdo con el regulador
de las telecomunicaciones o con el
podcast ha incrementado su popularidad
24 por ciento este año en relación al
año pasado y los géneros que son más
escuchados son en primer lugar el del
entretenimiento seguido de comedia
noticias y actualidad además durante una
encuesta se descubrió que el 67 por
ciento de las personas realiza otra
actividad mientras se escucha un podcast
cuando se traslada a otro lugar o
mientras maneja y los menores de 54 años
prefieren descargar podcast con vídeo en
la plataforma de youtube entre los
podcasts más populares en estos momentos
se encuentran los de deportes entre
ellos uno que incentiva a las personas
de 0 a 5 km de manera gradual
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana nuestro primer
programa de esta temporada hoy
analizando la rentrée en francia tanto
con los miedos que da toda la crisis del
coronavirus pero también a nivel
político y a nivel también de los
principales eventos que trae esta
rentrée y uno sin duda de ellos quizá el
principal sea el macroproceso iniciado
por los atentados de charly héctor lo
recuerdan en enero de 2015 que dejaron
contra el semanario satírico y contra el
supermercado de comida judía hiper
casera que en la capital francesa que
dejaron 17 muertos y sobre todo
cambiando la historia de este país quizá
para siempre estamos en esta mesa con
beatriz juez corresponsal del mundo
enric bonet corresponsal de público y
del punt y oliverio router director
general del observatorio europeo de
think tanks beatriz en que esperan de
este proceso de este macroproceso que se
ha iniciado ahora en parís que se va a
dilatar durante dos meses y que sobre
todo intenta establecer digamos las
complicidades de esos tres terroristas
que es un momento fueron abatidos sí
porque los terroristas no están muertos
o sea no están en el juicio son los que
se juzgan en los que son juzgados son
los
14 personas que son considerados
cómplices y lo que quieren ver y estoy
hablando con una de las abogadas antes
de que empezara el juicio y ella me
decía lo que quería querían es que
quedara claro que para cometer los
atentados si no tenían armas si no
tenían coches para fugarse si no tenían
apartamentos dónde esconderse no
hubiesen podido hacer los atentados
entonces ellos quieren que estas
personas que son cómplices sean juzgados
también y condenados por lo que hicieron
porque sin ellos los tres terroristas no
hubieran podido hacer los atentados
enrique cuando hablamos es verdad que el
adjetivo histórico ya muchas veces lo
utilizamos con demasiada ligereza pero
parece que esta vez sí que hay un cierto
consenso entre los medios la sociedad
francesa los políticos en que estamos
ante algo histórico no si hay sin duda
un juicio muy importante también porque
es el primero de una ola de atentados
que fue muy fuerte en francia que por el
impacto a nivel de número de muertos y
también como sacudió toda la sociedad
desde la francesa que tuvo lugar en 2015
primero con los atentados de enero y
luego los de noviembre en el bataclán
que será un juicio que seguramente
vendrá vendrá después a partir de
principios del año que viene pues si
estamos ante un juicio muy importante
pero al mismo tiempo como comenta la
compañera que podría ser un poco poco
frustrante o un juicio un poco que que
no son del todo fácil de explicar porque
cuando uno estaba el miércoles al inicio
de juicio veía a los 11 acusados en el
banquillo no tenían para nada el aspecto
de típicos y chavistas que con eso no
creo que quizás estudian tener un rol
importante en esos atentados pero no
está claro habrá que la justicia tendrá
que determinar cuál era el perfil de esa
gente que con su las ventas de armas con
las posibles formas de financiamiento
hasta qué punto sabían de que con lo que
hicieron se llevarían a cabo esos
atentados trágicos y son los expertos
claro y es el punto de la justicia
responder a esa pregunta a partir de qué
punto alguien es cómplice de los
atentados porque delimitar esa barrera
es muy complicado y eso es lo que se
pretende establecer en estos dos meses
coincidiendo con la fecha inicio de
curso la publicación searle y el dow ha
decidido republicano en su portada
aquellos dibujos que provocaron
la barbarie no sé si durante este
periodo hemos asistido a cierta
autocensura en cierta forma de triunfo
de los terroristas porque es verdad que
muy pocos se han atrevido con ello
además coincidió con la fecha
encontramos varios sondeos que indican
que incluso hay algo así como un 20 por
ciento de jóvenes que no llegan a
condenar los atentados de hecho el
hashtag génesis charly y en sí para
charly estuvo 103 topic en twitter en la
víspera del inicio del juicio que está
fallando cinco años después para que no
entendamos ciertas cosas para que no
condenemos esto nos guste o no nos guste
la publicación pues todo falla todo sí
porque a ver ese juicio se inserta en
una secuencia además digamos política
actual bastante especial con él en
francia al menos no voy a hablar del
black life
matters en eeuu pero en francia en todo
caso hay un debate creciente desde los
últimos años entre los que se declaran
indígena
los que
los que se consideran como islam o como
se llama cómplices o colaboradores o no
sé cómo se dice
y entonces bueno hay un trasfondo
político muy importante detrás de ese
juicio no sólo es un juicio criminal es
un juicio en realidad con carga política
muy muy importante en el que se
enfrentan en realidad dos paradigmas de
sociedad que estamos viendo ahora en el
debate político en el debate público
político con lo cual lo que ha fallado
yo creo es que por ejemplo ha habido
alta autocensura tanto por el miedo a
los atentados como a que uno reciba la
etiqueta de ser un racista un xenófobo
un islamófobo y con lo cual yo creo que
hace dos o tres días saliendo volvió a
publicar los dibujos cosas también
ningún otro periódico un lo hizo ninguno
durante todos estos años y es curioso
cuando tienen que ser un presidente del
gobierno como lo hizo en la víspera
manuel macro
a defender el derecho a la blasfemia en
un país como francia algo falla no lo
teníamos asumido que este derecho
existía
me pareció muy bien lo que escribieron
los periodistas echar libro para
justificar porque publicaban ahora las
caricaturas decían que esas caricaturas
se publican por primera vez en 2006 que
los jóvenes que están ahora viendo el
juicio de echar libro leyendo por la
prensa se repito no sabe nunca habían
vuelto a ver las caricaturas publicadas
no sabían de qué estaban hablando cuando
hablaban de las caricaturas de un
atentado ellos decían que consideraban
que era como una como un documento
histórico y un documento penal no esas
volver a publicar esas páginas para esas
caricaturas para que los jóvenes sepan
de qué se habla hablando porque unos
terroristas entraron a matar a charly
aunque no vean con sus propios ojos y es
importante cuando vemos que todavía hay
número del joven es muy importante que
no llega a condenar los atentados hay un
problema en este país
si hay un problema con todo esto pero
pero también imagino que también porque
sería un poco más lejos no no lo han
vivido de cerca eran pequeños cuando
pasó no saben lo que han pasado y a lo
mejor y si hubiesen vivido en ese
momento mejor lo condenarían pero cámara
les pilla como un poco lejos yo creo
bueno vamos a tratar los otros temas que
nos queda de política porque tenemos
muchísimos temas no sé si nos va a dar
para tratar todos pero bueno la rentrée
política que también está dando mucho
mucho de si se habla mucho de candidatos
en esta rentrée política tanto a derecha
como de izquierda se habla de rumores de
candidatos que pueden estar ahí
escenario que ahora mismo tenemos según
los sondeos y según lo que pasan las
últimas municipales creen que francia se
aproxima hacia 2022 con una tripolar y
zación entre mccrone y a ambos lados a
un lado le pen y la extrema derecha y al
otro un polo con los verdes
digamos hegemónicos en la izquierda ese
es el escenario que tenemos ahora mismo
más plausible de cara a 2022 enric si yo
completamente de acuerdo de que en
francia y nada tripolar polarización
entre ultraderecha la derecha más
liberal un centro de hecho liberal que
sería espacio de macrón y luego un
espacio de ecologista progresista luego
me du es quien va a liderar estos
espacios yo creo que el auto a la
derecha está clara que la candidata en
la primavera de 2022 era marie le pen
macro con todo apuntó a que se quiere
presentar aunque la duda de que si el
que fue el ex ministro
ministro tiene una popularidad que se
disparó no son dios si podría intentar
disfrutar de ese espacio aunque bueno
parece una hipótesis con la cuestión de
los viernes
importante los verdes sacaron muy buen
resultado en las últimas municipales
esto parece que los verdes va a subir
pero los verdes en francia siempre han
sido muy débiles en las elecciones
presidenciales donde sus candidatos
siempre han obtenido resultados muy
bajos y ahora estará la duda si en este
espacio donde hay otras formaciones
políticas como los socialistas la frente
e insumisa que a pesar de haber
debilitado mucho tiene cantidad de
potentes con iluminación que pasarán ese
espacio si se va a presentar divididos
lo que le resta muchas posibilidades o
van a encontrar un candidato o una
candidata de unidad que eso podría
cambiar para 2002 esto que describe mi
compañero enrique es el panorama que
tenemos sobre todo a partir de derivados
de esas municipales si lo recuerdan
antes de verano donde triunfaron sobre
todo los verdes y se hicieron con un
gran número de alcaldías y que ha pasado
este verano pues que nos ha surgido una
estrella aquí en francia que es nicolas
sarkozy el ex presidente casi se ha
convertido en un auténtico fenómeno
literario su nuevo libro es número uno
de ventas el presidente ha provocado
colas un auténtico
aval de firmas que sean comentan cada
fenómeno cada evento donde el firmado
sus libros se ha convertido en auténtico
evento una figura omnipresente que
siempre está ahí les sorprende ese
magnetismo de sarkozy olivia no una cosa
pero también hay que hay que matizar los
verdes también se han hecho con las
municipales con unas tasas de abstención
muy altas sí pero muy altas
es decir claro y entonces animar yo no
lo veo tan claro pero bueno ven con
ellos pero bueno y sarkozy sí porque es
lo que comentábamos antes es un animal
político es un animal político tiene
mucho carisma como lo tenías irak el
presidente chirac antes
siempre ha salido un poco de las
casillas clásicas de la figura del
tecnócrata que tiene olor y que tiene un
poco más con también ambas como yo creo
que ha gozado mucho de su juventud pero
sarkozy realmente goza de una especie de
carisma de presencia animal casi en el
escenario político muy importante y es
además un personaje digamos muy
discutido y polémico con causas sociales
y que polariza mucho con lo cual se le
odia o se le adora pero no deja
indiferente no es un presidente normal
no fue un presidente normal no es un
jubilado normal
a mí no me alucina mucho aquí en francia
es lo que venden los venden 200 mil
ejemplares en españa no sé yo creo que
ninguno tenía como 10 mil fans y no creo
que te sorprende este magnetismo no me
sorprende y yo creo que el compañero del
escrito muy bien la fuerza de sarkozy no
un animal político
un espacio político lo que está esta
derecha republicana que se quedó que la
huérfana se ha quedado huérfana
exactamente después de 2017 ahora que
muchos podrá la macro pero que no lo
terminan de sentir como suyo y luego
otro aspecto también muy importante para
explicar el fenómeno sarkozy es la
nostalgia es un elemento muy muy
presente en francia incluso lo vemos
casi con un presidente muy del estado
pero ahora cuando sacó un libro en 2018
que también tuvo un gran éxito literario
y esa nostalgia que ahora incluso en
francia se ve con sarkozy incluso ahora
que estamos un poco en el año de gol
porque esa conmemoración es de de gaulle
todo el mundo habla de de gaulle y es
verdad que la nostalgia es un
sentimiento central que impera en la
sociedad francesa a partir de ahí no sé
si creen que es posible una candidatura
de sarkozy 2022 ante la ante la inacción
en la derecha y yo creo que no pero no
soy sarkozy y no ha hablado conmigo
pero también estoy de acuerdo con
enrique en esto porque no hay que
confundir la nostalgia que ha entendido
muy bien el espíritu francés y la
nostalgia es una cosa y otra cosa es que
la gente se vaya a votar por sarkozy y
ya lo vimos en las últimas elecciones
presidenciales
y no gano ni en su propio partido ni en
su propio partido con lo cual yo creo
que se echa siempre de menos lo que ya
no está y se critica o se quiere echar
siempre lo que lo que es presente
entonces no sé si sarkozy realmente
tendría un apoyo político tan importante
como tiene ahora de digo de apoyo de
simpatía popular pues ahí nos quedamos
no sabemos si quise presentar a 2022
pero desde luego ha conseguido ser el
best seller del verano y el ex
presidente sarkozy muchísimas gracias a
los tres ya todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana quien en primera plana
gracias